you know that like success is something
that you define for yourself and it
can't really be defined by anybody else
for you I only want to make things that
are going to reach as many people as
possible I don't believe in these I
never want to settle I never want to be
like just happy with where I'm at I'm
just gonna prove you wrong I'd much
rather you sit there and be like huh I
was wrong anything anybody who's trying
to tell you like you need to gain like
monetary value like right now from your
art is somebody who is eating off of you
there's something really nice about like
having an idea and then running into the
room and then recording it yeah I want a
boss I don't think we need that this is
about life I'm trying to be real because
the internet isn't real but I'm
definitely not a rapper I don't want to
be RepRap errs can only get this fun I
don't want to be the guy on camera
beelin you should be following your
dreams and then people like I have five
kids he's an American actor comedian and
musician as a recording artist he
usually performs with the stage name
childish gambino he was nominated for
two Grammy Awards in 2015
he's donald glover and here are his top
ten rules for success define success for
yourself early
and it can change okay but just like you
know that like success is something that
you define for yourself and it can't
really be defined by anybody else for
you because everybody else comfortable
and you know you got it you got you
really have to believe in yourself and
not in a like believe in yourself way
but like anything like you know what
you're getting out of it like you can't
change a lot of things around you and
I'm like a lot of people are going to
tell you a lot of a lot of things you
have to have faith in yourself and I
like you know good friends around me so
I would just say like you know the
be good to yourself like me like you
know believe it yourself do what you
want and be like cool if it be okay like
family like yourself you know like it
like it you should be like nobody should
ever like you should never put out
something to be like this isn't a good
whatever like I like I think like I
think it's wack like that like
macklemore's like oh this album
shouldn't of one like Kendrick you
should have one up like that swag like
if you believe in that hobby should be
like I thought my album was bad because
like that's the thing I think my albums
like the best I love my elbow I think it
felt like if I was a kid I'd be like
this album's the truth like why not like
your own stuff so yeah like your stuff I
hate yeah I'm so tired of niche like
niche is something that like I'm glad to
see go away from this past decade like
it makes sense I guess like it makes
sense like after the after the internet
like that model makes sense for a lot of
things that gets like making a niche but
like I think we just needs to be smarter
like making making a product for only a
select few
you can definitely sustain that product
but I feel like the risk that you take
of like maybe it's good for everybody
and it's worth it because you know I
only want to make things that are going
to reach as many people as possible I
don't believe in niche like I think that
that is a really lame way that that that
comes from wanting more money yeah you
know like or just like being able not
even more money but stable money because
you know you can get and I'm just like
I'm not interested in making things safe
I just don't want to be okay with where
where I'm at like I never want to settle
I never want to be like just happy with
where I'm at like I always want to be
going for better yeah
I always get better at stuff not against
bullying I'm not a mean I'm not against
like bullying because I feel like the
world is bullies like there's so many
people who are going to tell you that
what you're at your idea is stupid or
like you don't belong here or you don't
deserve certain things and wouldn't it
be a better maybe a better place if
people didn't do that what you're saying
you you're not against against it's
unrealistic to be against I'm saying
like we probably wouldn't have Kanye
West Bill Gates or anyone without
someone being like you're not worth it
like we wouldn't have them and like we
wouldn't have people who were like no
this is worth it because if everybody if
everybody's ideas was worth it and if
they felt that way everybody felt like
that idea we just have it be just like
nothing everything would be the same you
need somebody to keep being like I don't
know I'm right you need a Joan of Arc
who's like no I'm right I'm right I'm
right I'm right even if it's crazy
even if it's great but like and then
eventually people like maybe they're not
are you that way
I mean yeah I like to believe that I
mean people seem like such a little
modest guy and when you're on the show
I'm a salty dude though are you oh yeah
I remember everybody who says that like
I mean like I got beats with people like
I remember stuff I remember totally and
I'm like most of the things I do is just
like nah I'm right like I believe in
myself your vengeful not vengeful I'm
salty I'm like the difference the
difference would be like vengeful is
like I'm gonna come and destroy you I
think like it's like I'm gonna win I'm
gonna take I've you taken your number
down and I'm and I'm coming for you no
matter for you I'm salty what you mean I
think salty is a different thing because
I'm like I'm just gonna prove you wrong
I'd much rather you sit there and be
like huh I was wrong because then I
think that's that's growing like there's
lots of times where I've done stuff in
me like I was wrong about that and I
didn't even know and then it makes you
like look at things differently um
experiences in your life like I I want
to make people think like you were wrong
I think like you know anybody who has
control over their art should just be
doing it
like I made a short film and that was
just our
yeah I just I just wanted to make that
anything anybody who's trying to tell
you like you need to gain like monetary
value like right now from your art is
somebody who is eating off of you it's
like immediate like that's the truth
that somebody who somebody who's eating
off of you and but the thing is like
you're eating off of you because you I
only seem like what I want to make I
don't that's all I see like when people
ask like are you want to do this do you
want to better land like I only see the
thing I'm supposed to make I'm not
concerned on whether or not what's a
called or like is this called painting
or music or whatever I'm just this is
the thing I'm supposed to make and I go
go to it so so worrying about monetary
value or like are people gonna pay for
this is only gonna like ruin this mmm
it's only gonna make this less of what I
wanted to be and yeah I mean that's I
don't I don't want to like make albums
or like toys or is it good I want to
make concepts that people are like wow
like this really changed you know I have
dreams where like things are still like
upside down when I turn them stuff like
and I'm still trying to figure out how
to do that in real life yeah yeah I just
I don't see the point in like cutting
yourself short and I know like people
it's weird like no I don't think it's
weird I think it's just kind of so much
like oh it's pretentious like to not
like studios and like it feels like yeah
but I don't know any artists will really
like studios like not because like
studio is a bad place is just like you
know you I feel like I'm wasting money
there like every time I'm not like doing
something I'm like like this our cost
blah blah blah there's something really
nice about like having an idea and then
running
recording it not worrying about you know
anything other than my gear yang with
your friends so like we kind of I just
tried to make the by like you know
you're making something with your
friends the more people who enjoy
something the more likely everybody else
wills like you know you have like a
testing market in your house and you're
hanging out with people who are
like-minded you said you never want to
work for anyone yeah I don't want a boss
I don't think we need that we live in a
time we live in a time now where it's
like easier now than ever to do anything
like I don't understand like people come
up to me like how do I start making a
movie or how do I was like you got a
phone like film if I had a phone when I
was like 7 yeah I would have made every
movie I ever thought I just would be
doing it all the time there's a lot of
like that's the thing where we're
fighting for what I'm fighting for right
now and not just I'm not doing this any
music this is not about rap I'm an
artist this is about life I'm trying to
be real because the internet isn't real
there's so much that happens online and
people perceive it and it's packaged is
real but nothing's real in my mid like
that's the reasons like people like this
Donald looks awkward there's a mistake
here I'm like yeah cuz it's real I'm
constantly trying to be real so like
that's the thing is I if I say so Donald
look what I got news for you guess what
Donald is awkward I haven't all the way
but that's the thing I am though and
that's what makes me mean you got to
deal with it so I was like I don't I'm
not in also like I'm not worried like
yeah like I can figure it out like I'm
not a dummy like I and I stand up for
what I believe in like and hip is not
about hip hop is about life like this is
real I represent real I'm trying to do
real stuff I sort of feel like I've said
this before like like I listed Kanye
interviews and he's like I can't go any
farther like a glass and like I used to
want to be like I need to be a rapper
like I'm trying
be like a rapper and just do all the
stuff and I was like oh man I realize
like yo that's my superpower I'm not a
rapper I'm definitely not a rapper I
don't want to be rep rappers can only
get this far like they can only go so
far and I want like this is a gift like
I get to make this show like it's
something that nobody else gets to make
it and make it weird and personal and
something that I think no one they
wouldn't let probably they wouldn't let
schoolboy q do it even though he's
probably got crazy dope ideas you know
but like I think this is my like
superpower or one I like yeah like I
want to do something don't I guess the
worst thing that could happen to me
right now would be if I just couldn't
make things anymore
like that there wasn't an outlet and be
honest like I feel like I think the one
thing I'm thankful for is that like you
I can still like change stuff play as
higher you still do things differently
like like I meant that when I wrote that
in the histogram is like and you can
always be better
I got seriously met that so I guess I'm
very thankful that like you know things
aren't always over it because no one
feels like they're good enough yeah like
no one does like everybody we all I mean
like I hauled it 28 it so yeah we were
all like around the age where it was
like like jobs weren't there after they
came and people were just kind of like
oh that's what I feel like I'm being
lied to because it's just like everybody
kind of became a freelance photographer
freelance today everybody became a
freelance that thing and then you
realize like oh man no one's really
happy like it's like no one really knows
really happy because we're not obtaining
those goals that everybody told which
ones have kids and do like all these
things
yeah we're suppose and no one's really
happy because like they realize like all
those things are kind of not what make
you happy but that's what our parents
did to like have purpose they were like
at and now we have all that stuff and
like the thing we're supposed to do is
really be helping each other but we've
been brought up in this kind of like
well I'm supposed to be like the the
top-ranking manager at this thing by
this point I have the
and it's not and it's not real it's just
not real it's not necessary everybody
should be just following their passion
because they're gonna be good at that at
most but like people are too worried
about you know you know their jobs cuz
people gotta eat it's that it's not sad
but it's just like it's true like people
gotta eat and I feel bad like I don't
want to be the guy on camera be like you
should be following your dreams and then
people like I have five kids you know
you know I can't do that but I I think
it's true like people are scared and
vulnerable it's it is it's dangerous to
do that but I don't think we're gonna
grow if we don't thank you so much for
watching I made this video because John
Hwang asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave me in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do I'd also love to
know which of the top ten rules hit you
the hardest can have the biggest impact
leave it in the comments and I'll join
the discussion and my personal goal in
the channel is to get it to 1 million
subscribers so anything you could think
of to do to share the video spread it
tell friends about it tweet it
I'd really deeply appreciate it thank
you guys so much for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon